generally when you think about artificial intelligence
you are talking about whats the difference between
einstein and normal people
or between a normal person and a stupid person
actually it's like difference between normal person and a mouse??!
or what's the difference between mouse and a rock??
like that's the...that's the difference in ..umm ..between just levels of intelligence within humans which actually ...actually doesnt vary that much
in the grand scheme of things vs. whats intelligence is in general
one way of thinking about what intelligence is ..is
as an optimization process  .most basic of all optimization process is evolution
which ...umm..is looking for good replicators in the search space of animals ..right??
..or creatures..or umm..organisms..yeah..Organisms is the word!